مشاهدينا اهلا بكم شكرا لخالد انا ميسون
عزام واحييكم ونستمر معكم في هذه التغطيه
للاحداث في السودان اقل من ساعتين تفصلنا
عن هدنه مرتقبه بدءا من السادسه مساء
بتوقيت الخرطوم نتحدث عن السابعه بتوقيت
السعوديه ورغم الشكوك حول الالتزام
بالهدنه الا ان مسؤولين في الجيش السوداني
والدعم السريع اكدال العربيه موافقتهما
على هدنه لمده 24 ساعه في الاثناء اكدت
قيادات عسكريه سودانيه للعربيه اكدت ان
الجيش يعمل على بسط سيطرته على قاعده مروي
وعلى مطاررها ايضا حيث اكد مراسل العربيه
في مراوين انسحاب مجموعات كبيره تابعه
للدعم السريع من داخل المطار شاهدنا ايضا
بعض الصور التي وردت من هناك حول هذا
الخروج الداخليه السودانيه اصدرت اليوم
قرارا بانهاء انتداب جميع ضباط الشرطه
بقوات الدعم السريع في ما طلبت لجنه اطباء
السودان بوقف استهداف البنى التحتيه
للمستشفيات والذي يفاقم من انهيار الخدمات
الصحيه
[موسيقى]
احداث متسارعه يشهدها السودان في رابع
ايام الاشتباكات الداميه بين الجيش وقوات
الدعم السريع لكن الرؤيه النهائيه بشان
الطرف العسكري الذي سيبسط سيطرته على
الارض لم تتضح حتى هذه اللحظه تعددت
الروايات بين الاطراف المتنازعه والمتضرر
واحد الشعب السوداني الذي عان وما زال من
هذه الصراعات معدلات القتل والاصابات
تتزايد بوتيره متفاقمه والعديد من
المستشفيات خرجت عن الخدمه فبعضها ضربت
بالقذائف والبعض الاخر انقطعت عنه
الكهرباء ولا يجد للامدادات الطبيه سبيله
اذا استمر القتال سيكون هناك المزيد من
الضحايا الارقام التي حصلت عليها لم يتم
تاكيدها نحن نعتمد على معلومات من الاطباء
السودانيين ومن المستشفيات حتى الان قتل
ما لا يقل عن 185 شخصا وا اكثر من 1800
شخص بمن فيهم مدنيون وعناصر الجيش تحرك
صعب يواجه السكان في ظل القصف الجوي
والاشتباكات العنيفه على الارض
واماكن متفرقه احتجز فيها السودانيون منذ
بدايه الاشتباكات ومنها الجامعات غير
المجهزه لحال كهذه والعديد من هؤلاء
المحتجزين حاولوا الخروج للعوده الى
منازلهم اثناء هدنه وقف اطلاق النار التي
دعت اليها بعثه الامم المتحده الا ان
الاطراف المتصارعه لم تلتزم بها رغم
التعهدات باحترامها
احنا حوالي 88
نفر مننا عشرين عامل
فيهم كبار السن
وفي حوالي خمسه طالبات المعارك في السودان
احدثت نكسه غذائيه بسبب صعوبه التنقل
وارتفاع الاسعار وسط تعليق العشرات من
برامج المساعدات الانسانيه بعد ان نهبت
الامدادات ودمرت المساعدات لا يمكنني
اعطائك اي ارقام محدده حول قيمه الممتلكات
المسروقه او الامدادات المنهوبه او حتى
المساعدات التي دمرت بسبب القتال كما قلت
في وقت سابق في هذه الظروف لا يمكن ان
يحدث اي توصيل للمساعدات بشكل اساسي تمديد
وقلق امميان واطراف اقليميه ودوليه تقف
على خط الازمه التي ساحت ثالثه اكبر بلد
افريقي الا ان تلك المساعي والمحاولات
المتعدده لم تجد اذانا صاغيه حتى الان
سلطان العيبان العربيه
اذا مشاهدينا ساعتان عن الهدنه طبعا الحدث
الاهم حاليا في السودان عضو مجلس السياده
الانتقال السوداني شمس الدين كباشي اكد في
تصريحات للعربيه ان المجلس وافق على هدنه
مقترحه من الامم المتحده لمده 24 ساعه
بشرط ضمان ضبط قوه الدعم السريع مضيفا انه
سيتم الالتزام بالهدنه وبمراقبه مدى
التزام الدعم السريع بها وعبر الكباشي عن
اسف مجلس السياده من التصعيد الحاصل ومن
فشل التهدئه في البلاد مشيرا الى ان
القوات المسلحه كانت مضطره لدخول المعركه
كشف المتحدث نفسه ان الانشقاقات داخل
الدعم السريع صحيحه مئه بالمئه مضيفا ان
قوات الدعم السريه تستعد لاستقبال طائرات
مساعدات في مروي
[موسيقى]
الامور عندنا مسيطره عليها تماما نحن نقدر
الوضع انها ان هذه حرب حرب حرب مدن وحرب
المدن معقده ولذلك نحن نتعامل معها وفقا
لذلك الخرطوم مقتضى بالسكان وبالعمران
ولذلك نحن نتعامل مع هذه الحرب بحسابات
دقيقه جدا حتى القوه
انها بق
در بقدر ما نحتاجه بقدر الموقف الذي
امامنا صحيح ما استخدم الطيران احيانا
لضرب
بعض المقرات التي لا زالت لديهم ايضا لقطع
خطوط امدادهم
نحن ليست لدينا مشكله مع قوات الدعم
السريع في جزء كبير جدا من معاصره من
الضباط ووحدات كامله يمكن نقلت من القوات
المسلحه
عند انشائها
ما بينما يقوم به
محمد حمدان وشقيقي
احنا الامور ستمضي وتاخد وجهات القانونيه
ولكن سنعمل على توفيق اوضاع هذه
القوات
وامر الترتيبات العسكريه اللازمه
وفي المقابل اكد يوسف عزت وهو المستشار
السياسي لنائب رئيس مجلس السياده وايضا
قائد قوات الدعم السريعه اكد في مقابله مع
العربيه ان قوات الدعم السريه لا تعترض
على الهدنه وانها ستتصرف بمسؤوليه كامله
تجاه هذه الهدنه
[تصفيق]
من جهتي رئيس حركه العدل والمستوجب ريل
ابراهيم والذي يشغل منصب وزير الماليه
الدعم بدوره الجيش السوداني ودعا ايضا
قوات الدعم السريع الاحترام الهدنه الهدنه
المؤقته لمده 24 ساعه حتى يتم دفن الجثث
واخلاء الجرحى وفتح ممرات امنه لخروج
المدنيين المحاصرين في مناطق الاقتتال
بجانب تمكين السلطات من اعاده خدمات
المياه والكهرباء الى المناطق التي فقدت
منها هذه الخدمات
[تصفيق]
الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر لسه لسه
الله اكبر
[موسيقى]
نعم يعني قبل ساعتين تقريبا او ساعه
وخمسين دقيقه حتى نكون اكثر دقه
شهود عيان نقلوا للعربيه قبل قليل
مشاهداتهم بان الطيران الجو او طيران
عسكري حلق في
السماء منطقه المطلقه التي تبعد نحو 100
كم جنوبي مدينه مروي والقاعده العسكريه
هذا الطيران حلق بموازات وجود نحو 130
سياره كانت قد خرجت او انسحبت من مطار
مروي الدولي واتجهت جنوبا الطيران العسكري
او الحربي بحسب شهود العيان قام بقصف هذه
السيارات التي انتشرت في احد المشاريع
الزراعيه في هذه المنطقه جنوبي مروي
وتعامل معهم عسكريا شهود العيان ايضا
اكدوا بان معظم السيارات تبع
منها من اخذ طرقا غير التي كان يسير بها
في الطريق الرئيس الذي يغضب بين مدينه ام
درمان ومدينه مروي هذا هو المشهد الراهن
والاخبار المحدثه نضيف الى ان مصادر
عسكريه كانت قد اكدت لي قناه العربيه بان
القوه التي كانت تتمركز داخل مطار مروي
الدولي والقاعده الجويه العسكريه العمليه
في مروي قد انسحبت نحو ثلاث ساعات
وان القوات المسلحه السودانيه كانت قد
استخدمت المدفعيه الثقيله
والقذائف وحاولت هذه القوه من التابع
لقوات الدعم السريه ان تستخدم ذات القوه
حتى لا تقرض ولكنها بحسب الجيش انسحبت من
خارج مطار مروي الدولي وهذا يجيب على
تساؤل في حينها عندما شاهدنا صور صور
انسحاب هذه الاليات ان كان هناك نوع من
التنسيق او لا يبدو انه الق كانت متعلقه
في ان يكونوا بمسافه بعيده بعض الشيء عن
المطار الاستهدافهم اذا الطيران العسكري
استهدف السيارات التي شاهدنا مشاهدينا صور
لها تخرج من مطار مروي قبل حوالي
من الان وطبعا كان هناك الحديث ان مجموعات
كبيره قد خرجت وهي تابعه للدعم السريع
اعود اليك نزار للحديث عن اجواء المطار
والاستهدافات والوضع في محيط المطار كيف
هو
الان الهدوء ومن يطوق الاوضاع هنا في مطار
مروي وفي القاعده الجويه لا قصف مدفع الان
لا نسمع اصوات
لطائرات عسكريه في محيط وفي حرم وفي فضاء
المطار لا نشاهد اعمده دخان تتصاعد ولا
نشاهد السنت لهب يبدو ان الامور الان
هادئه تماما في محيط المطار وحتى داخل
مدينه مروي المواطنون في هذه المدينه
يتابعون عن كثب كل هذه التطورات اول باول
يبدو اننا فقدنا الاتصال مع مراسل العربيه
نزار بقداوي كان معنا من مروي ولكنه اكد
ان الصور التي شاهدناها للاليات العسكريه
والمجموعات الكبيره التابعه للدعم السريع
التي كانت قبل حوالي الساعتين من الان قد
خرجت وشهدنا صورها على الشاشه خرجت من
مطار مروي قد تم استهدافها بعد ابتعادها
عن المطار وذلك من خلال الطيران العسكري
ايضا انتشر على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
مشاهد لانتشار الجيش السوداني في بعض
الشوارع في العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم
المشاهد اوضحت انتشار المدرعات وايضا
الاليات التابعه للجيش السوداني في
الشوارع السودانيه المتابعه
[موسيقى]
وعلى كل نعود الى مراسل العربيه في مروى
نزار بقداوي وايضا سالم الهاشمي معنا من
الخرطوم ولكن اكمل مع نزار فيما يتعلق
بالوضع في مروي وكوننا نتحدث عن وجود
انتشار للجيش السوداني داخل الخرطوم كان
هناك طبعا حديث عن انه الدعم السريع
قواتها منتشره في الخرطوم يبدو ان هناك
انتشار الان للجيش السوداني كما شاهدنا من
خلال هذه الصور ماذا عن مروي
والمدينه بحد ذاتها
يمكن الحديث الان عن مرحله جديده من مراحل
هذه العمليه العسكريه التي دخلت يومها
الرابع كنا قبل ان نتحدث قبل نصف ساعه من
الان او قبل ساعه كان الحديث وكانت
الاخبار تنقل بان المشهد يتكون من عنصرين
اساسيين المشهد العسكري والميداني نقصد
هنا القوات المسلحه السودانيه تنتشر في
محيط المطار وتنتشر في ارتكازات متعدده
ايضا وجود لقوات الدعم السريع داخل الحرم
المطار وداخل القاعده الان بعد هذه
المعطيات وبعد هذه التطورات الحديث فقد عن
وجود لقوات الجيش السوداني القوات المسلحه
السودانيه داخل مدينه مروي وفي داخل
المطار وفي حرم المطار وامام البوابه
الرئيسه في المطار الى جانب وجود لقوات
الفرقه التاسعه عشر مشاه
والمدفعيه التي وصلت ايضا كدعمه وسند
للقوات الموجوده
كان قبل ان نتحدث عن وجود قوات الدعم
السريع الان بعد هذا الانسحاب يبدو ان
الحديث فقط عن وجود للقوات المسلحه
السودانيه تحديدا في محليه مروي الى ان
تصدر تاكيدات رسميه من قبل الجيش السوداني
ومن قبل المتحدث باسم الجيش
تؤكد تماما الخلوق الرسمي بقوات الدعم من
هذا المطار واستلام هذا المطار تماما
بسيطره كامله للجيش تظل الوضعيه على ما هو
عليه قوات للجيش السوداني تنتشر في حدود
مروي وفي حدود المطار وقوات تتبع للدعم
السريع انسحبت والان تنتشر في الحدود
الجنوبيه لمحليه وسنتعرف اكثر عن التفاصيل
اسمح لي ان انتقل الى مراسلنا في الخرطوم
سالم ليطلعنا على الاوضاع قبل ساعتين من
بدء الهدنه المنتظره
هذه
الاحاسيس التي هي موجوده في الشارع الان
بالحديث عن هذه الهدنه موجوده استبشار من
كثير من المواطنين بهذه الهدنه ونظره منهم
الى ان هذه الهدنه قد تحقق ما يريدون وما
يخصمون اليه هذا في جانب الجانب الثاني
هناك تحدي بمدى قدره الجانبين لتحقيقه
حقيقيه يستفيد منها المواطن
ويستطيع تحقيق ما يريده من ايصال ما
يحتاجونه من مواد غذائيه وادويه وغيرها من
الاحتياجات التي يطالب بها المواطنون هنا
في الفرق
نعم وماذا عن الاوضاع بصوره عامه وهل بدات
تتضح الصوره من يسيطر على ماذا على الارض
شاهدنا قبل قليل بعض الصور للجيش ينتشر
بينما كان هناك حديث وانباء عن ان الدعم
السريع هو من ينتشر على الارض من يسبب نوع
بحسب طبعا وصفه الجيش السوداني نوع من
المخاوف ان كان على المدنيين ان كان ايضا
على المقرات الرسميه وايضا البعثات
الدوليه
اصعب الحديث عن مساله من يسيطر على من
يؤمن يستطيع ان يحقق مكاسب اعلى هذه الحرب
وما زالت دائره حتى الان هذه واحده
الثانيه انه على مستوى الشارع في مناطق
التي ليس فيها لا يوجد فيها مظاهر عسكريه
وانما يستمع الى صوت الرصاص وصوت القنابل
والاصوات التي اصوات الحرب بكل تاكيد التي
تجبر المواطنين على الجلوس في اماكنهم لكن
الى هذه اللحظه لا تتضح رؤيه واضحه يستطيع
احد ان يجزم بها بان هذا حسن او هذا سيطر
وكذا لاننا يعني مساله الحسم النهائي
دائما ما تكون
حينما لابد ان يكون هناك طرف
تم يعني اعلن انه سيطر على كل هذه المنطقه
ويتوقف السماع اصوات
قد ايه في تفاؤل من انه هذه الهدنه بالفعل
ستطبق وان هناك نيه حقيقيه من قبل الطرفين
لتطبيقها
ربما في تجربتنا مع الهدلتين السابقتين
الثلاث ساعات والاربع ساعات في التجربه
هذه لم ينجح الطرفان في تحقيق هذه الهمه
صراحه لانه مع انطلاق الهدنه انطلقت
الاشتباكات واستمرت هذه الاشتباسات الى ما
بعد الهدنه
فيبقى التحدي في قدره الطرفين على تحقيق
هذه الهدنه من خلال 24 ساعه طيب الى اي حد
هناك لازال حراك ربما القول ونتمنى ان
يكون نشط فيما يتعلق بالمحاوله الى الوصول
الى هدنه شامله للوصول الى حلول ربما او
الى امكانيه التفاوض بين الطرفين استمعنا
انه اخر الحراك كان من قبل الجانب
الامريكي هل من اتصالات اخرى نعلم بها
سالم
نعم لا توجد حتى الان سوى المبادره التي
اطلقها السياسيون هنا في الخرطوم مثل حزب
الامه القومي ايضا الحريه والتغيير اليوم
اكثرت بيانا كذلك تحدثت فيه ووقعت عليه
عدد من القوى السياسيه او القوى المؤثره
على الارض وهذا البياري هو ضد الحرب
وتصعيد الحرب كذلك هم 42 جسم بقياده
الحريه والتغيير ودعوا للتعبئه الاعلام
الاضراب السياسي والعصيان المدني الشامل
متوحدون حول موقف المناهض للحرب
والاستمرارها ومتوحدون حول رفض عوده فروج
نظام السابق الى المشهد السياسي ونعتزم
الاتفاق على اليه مشتركه لمتابعه التطورات
وتنسيق المواقف وان استمرار الحرب خلفه
ولا يزال يخلف اثارا تاريخيه الجيش والدعم
السريع لم يلتزم بالهدنه التي اعلنت سابقا
ولم تحدد الممرات الامنه لاجلاء العالقين
هذه
الاجسام التي وقعت على هذا
طيب وهذا بالنسبه للمبادرات ولكن يبدو حتى
الان
بحسب التصريحات وخاصه لما سمعنا من كباش
ان لا تفاوض يمكن ان يكون ولكن هل للاحزاب
حظه الان على اي من الاطراف ام انه العامل
الخارجي هو ربما الذي يمكن ان يحرك
الطرفين للتفاوض او على الاقل للوصول الى
ما بعد الهدنه من تهدئه
بحسب ما يفهم من حديث قائد الجيش وحتى
اعظم السياده في افاداتهم
المقتضبه جدا في هذه الفتره يفهم منها
انهم لن يقاوضوا ابدا في هذا في هذه
المساله وانه مامون في حسم التفلتات
وقالوا هذا الامر غراضا بانهم سينضون في
حسم اي تخلت وان هذه من التفلتات هو
هذه هذا التفلت لن يجعلونه لن يجعلوه يمضي
هكذا لابد ان يحسم حسما كاملا ويفهم من
سياق كلامهم انهم لم يقبلوا حتى من
النداءات التي رفعتها والختارات التي
رفعتها القوات المسلحه لن تقبل الا اذا
استسلم قوات الدعم السريع وربما هنا توقف
الحرب على كل من ابقى معي سالم وايضا يبقى
معي نزار ولكن دعونا نتحدث الان ونركز على
الجانب الانساني الاخطر والذي على اساسه
تم الوصول الى هذه الهدنه قوات الدعم
السريع اتهمت قياده القوات المسلحه بتوجيه
ضربه عسكريه بالطيران الحربي للدائره
الطبيه لقوات الدعم السريع التي تقع طبعا
داخل نطاق وتواجد المدنيين بحي شمبات
بمدينه بحري وقد استهدفت الضربه العسكريه
بحسب الدعم السريع اسرى القوات المسلحه
والمصابين من الطرفين والمدنيين الذين
يتلقون المساعدات الطبيه والانسانيه داخل
مستشفى الدائره الطبيه
وايضا فيما يتعلق بالوضع الطبي والانسان
نقابه الاطباء في السودان اكدت على تضرر
المبنى الاداري مبنى الحوادث ايضا وخزان
المياه بمستشفى الشعب
ودامت نقابه الاطباء قصف مستشفى الشعب
بالطيران الذي تم ضرب المبنى الاداري
ومبنى الحوادث وصهريج المياه صهريج مياه
المستشفى مستشفى الخرطوم وايضا سكن
الممرضات
بالمستشفى
ومضيفه ان استهداف البنى التحتيه
للمستشفيات عمل تمتد اثاره لسنوات قادمه
حيث سيفاقم انهيار الخدمات الصحيه
المنهاره اصلا
وزاره الصحه السودانيه قالت ان القطاع
الصحي في الخرطوم وجه انهيار بسبب تضاؤل
امدادات الطاقه مضيفه ان المستشفيات في
حاجه لاستدامه عمل المولدات الاحتياطيه من
اجل تقديم الخدمات الصحيه الاساسيه اشارت
الصحه السودانيه الى ان كل الولايات
السودان تعاني من نقص حاد في اكياس الدم
داعيه في الوقت ذاته الى ايجاد حل مستدام
لنقص امدادات الطاقه في المرافق الصحيه
وايضا في بنك الدم
الاتحاد الدولي لجمعيات الصليب الاحمر
والهلال الاحمر قال انه يكاد ان يكون من
المستحيل تقديم الخدمات الانسانيه داخل
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم وما حول
العاصمه ايضا حذر من ان النظام الصحي في
البلاد معرض لخطر الانهيار
دعونا نتعرف على الوضع والنظام الصحي في
كل منطقه نتحدث من مروي معنى لازال مراسل
العربيه نزار بقداوي نزار خبرنا عن وضع
القطاع الصحي وهل من امكانيه للتحرك
للمدنيين للتواقم الصحيه ايضا من جهه الى
اخرى
الواقع الصحي والواقع
التعل
تداعيات هذه العمليه العسكريه التي استمرت
لاربعه ايام على المدنيين هنا في الولايه
الشماليه تحديدا في منطقه مروي التي تعتبر
المسرح الرئيس للعمليه العسكريه هنا في
شمال السودان الواقع مختلف بعض الشيء عما
دور هنالك في العاصمه المثلثه الخرطوم في
كل من ام درمان والخرطوم بحري ومدينه
الخرطوم العاصمه هنا في مروي المدنيون لم
يتاثروا تاثيرا مباشرا بهذه الاحداث وهذه
العمليات العسكريه في اليوم الاول فقط
عندما تمت الاشتباكات في الساعات الاولى
كانت هنالك اصابات طفيفه في صفوف المدنيين
نحو خمس اصابات جاءت نتيجه للتعرض بعض
البيوت
لشظايا اطلقت من داخل القاعده الجويه ومن
داخل المطار بعد اشتداد
الاشت باكات بين الطرفين تم اسعاف
المصابين تلقوا العلاج تلقوا العلاج في
مستشفيات هنا في المنطقه التي نتحدث فيها
يوجد المستشفى العسكري القومي وهو يقدم
الخدمه الطبيه
لمنصوبي القوات النظاميه وللمدنيين هنالك
ايضا مستشفى الضمان وهو ايضا يقدم خدماته
الى جانب مستشفى اخر خاص يقدم خدمه علاجيه
للمرضى والمصابين وللمدنيين في مدينه
كريمه المدينه الاخرى وهي اسم مدن هذه
الولايه الشماليه ايضا المصابون من القوات
المسلحه تم نقلهم الى هذا المستشفى ايضا
نتحدث عن مستشفى مدينه دنبله التعليمي وهو
ايضا مستشفى يضاف الى سلسله المرافق
الصحيه الموجوده هنا في الولايه الشماليه
لا حديث حتى الان عن ضغط
يواجه به النظام الصحي الشماليه حديث بعض
الشيء من قبل منسوبي بعض الكوادر بامكانيه
ان يتدخل الكادر الطبي في حاله الضروره
لكن حجم الاصابات التي وصلت الى
المستشفيات لم تكن بالقدر الذي يجعل من
النظام الصحي في هذه الولايه معرضا لمزيد
من الضغط كما هو الحال في الخرطوم وام
درمان والخرطوم بحري طيب ودعنا نلقي نظره
على الوضع
وقطاع الصحي في الخرطوم تحدثنا قليلا عما
يوصف ولكن من مشاهداتك سالم ماذا تقول
سالم هل تسمعني
طيب يبدو اننا فقدنا الاتصال طيب تفضل كنا
نتحدث عن القطاع الصحي يبدو ان انه في
الخرطوم تحديدا استهدف ان كان بالبنى
التحتيه وغيره بطريقه قويه جدا اثرت ان
كان على تحرك الاطقم الطبيه او حتى عاملهم
في الداخل مشاهداتك سالم
اما هناك
استهداف تمالي بعض
المؤسسات الصحيه منها مستشفى ابن سينا
مثلا كذلك مستشفى بحري التخصصي هذه
المسيحيين الذين نؤكد انهما تم استهدافهم
في هذه الحرب ايضا تاثرت بعض البنى
التحتيه خاصه في مستشفى بحري وحدة في
المستشفى ابن سينا
واصبح المستشفيان
الخدمه الان كذلك من المستشفيات التي
تاثرت تاثرت في اوضاع اخرى
اوضاع مثلا في مساله الدعم المتعلق
بالمستشفى ولا المعينات الصحيه على عمل
الطوارئ والاصابات هناك مستشار تاثرت
بالقطاع التيار المائي عنها والكهرباء
كذلك هناك مستشفيات ايضا تاثرت بعدم قدره
وصول الكوادر الطبيه الكافيه لتشغيل هذا
المستشفى كل هذه العوامل اثرت على بعض
المرافق الصحيه القطاع الصحي حقيقه لديه
معاناه كبيره
وينتظره تحدي في هذه الهدنه بقدرته على
ايصال المساعدات وكذلك توفير المياه
للمستشفيات وهذا ما وعدت به وزاره
الداخليه عبر الدفاع المدني حينما اوصت
الدفاع المدني بتوفير مياه الشرب
للمستشفيات والمرافق الصحيه وكذلك
المواطنين طيب سالم نحن نعلم ان هناك
جاليات مختلفه منها المصريه وغيرها
متواجده بالسودان وفي ظل اغلاق المطار
وتوقف الرحلات ما مصير هؤلاء وكيف يتم
دعمهم على الارض
نعم بالنسبه لهذا الاغلاق المفاجئ الى
الان لم تصدر الدوله بيانا رسميا عن مساله
هذا الاغلاق والحلول المقترحه لهذا
الاغلاق لاغلاق مطار الخرطوم هذا الاغلاق
كم هي الفتره التي سيستغرقها هذا الاغلاق
للمطار وهل هناك بدائل لمطارات اخرى الى
هذه اللحظه لم تصدر الدوله اي بيان رسمي
يعلق على هذا الحدث على كل ام كان معنا من
الخرطوم مراسل العربيه سالم الهاشمي شكرا
جزيلا لك واشكر مراسل العربيه من مروي
نزار بقداوي على المعلومات التي قدمت
وثقت كاميرا العربيه لحظه حدوث انفجار في
محيط مباني القياده العامه للقوات المسلحه
السودانيه في العاصمه الخرطوم دعونا نتابع
والمزيد معنا من القاهره الدكتور محمد عز
الدين رئيس مؤسسه النيل للدراسات
الافريقيه والاستراتيجيه اهلا بك دكتور
اسمح لي انا ابدا بقراءتك للمشهد الان اين
وصلنا وبالمقابل ما الذي يمكن له ان يدفع
هذه الاطراف للقبول بهدنه بعد اربعه ايام
من الاقتتال
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم طبعا للاسف الشديد
انزلقت الخرطوم الى الاقتتال بشكل سريع
جدا برغم ان يعني كنا نترقب هذا الاقتتال
منذ سنتين مضت يعني منذ بدء الثوره
السودانيه
خاصه ان يعني هناك عدد من الجيوش داخل
الخرطوم ليس جيش واحد عندك الجيش القوات
الدعم السريع الجيش الرسمي وهي جيش الشعب
الذي يقاتل من اجله اليوم وعندك الجيوش
الهامش او الجيوش
النضال كما يسمونه الذين كانوا يناضلوا في
الهامش في منطقه دارفور فبالتالي هذا
الاقتتال كان مرتقب منذ يعني
مده طويله مضت لكن تاخر
واتت ولكن اتت بشكل قوي ما بين اهم
فاصلين هو جيش الدوله الرسمي والقوات
الدعم السريع التي كانت في طريقها لان
تصبح قوه رسميه
يعتد به داخل الدوله السودانيه لكن للاسف
الشديد
كل كل يعني محمد حمدان دوقله يعني ما الذي
فكر فيه لكي ينهار بقواته بهذا الشكل
وينزلق بهم الى هذا المنزلقه الخطير لازم
دكتور محمد من تقوم
احد يعلم ما الذي حدث
للاسف الشديد الذي حدث
نحن
كباحثين نراقب الاجواء في كل دوله افريقيه
بحكم مؤسسه النيل للاسف الشديد هناك
حب
التحكم والحكم للاسف الشديد اوصلت الى ان
يعتقد انه الشارع انه يمتلك الشارع
بدخوله منطقه مروي
بدعوه
محاربه الجيش المصري هناك
واستعداء مصر
وكزب الشارع السوداني بهذه الطريقه
سيرفعونه الى الاعناق ويدعنه محل رئيس
المجلس السيادي وهذا كان خطا كبير جدا
للاسف الشديد تم استدراج محمد حمدان يصل
الى هذا
الاستدراجه من قبل من ولن ادخل بتفاصيل
القضيه المصريه بمعنى الجنود المتواجدين
هناك لانه التصريحات الرسميه تتحدث عن ان
تواجدهم هو للمناوره ليس الا لاجراء
مناورات طبعا مع الجيش السوداني ولكن دعني
ولكن
سبق اولا لتوضيح لهذه النقطه دكتور من
استدرج حمدتي الى هذه النقطه لانه
الروايات كلها تميل على انه ربما
فلول النظام هم تتحركوا على الارض ولم يكن
حتى
للقائدين
اليد في ذلك ولكن اعتقد ان
اعتقد ان ان هناك بعض الجهات والاحزاب
داخل السودان استدرجته بالاضافه الى جهاز
خارجيه
اعطته امل ان يكون هو القائد المرتقب
للسودان هناك
جهاد وكان يدعو للديمقراطيه فبالتالي
اعتقد ان قحط من كانت تدعوه لان يكون هو
رجل الديمقراطي القادم
واعطته امل على ذلك
اضافه الى بس خليني لانه بحب اعرف المشهد
الى اين نتجه الان وخاصه انك ذكرت انه
فقط على الجيش السوداني ولا تقتصر على
الدعم السريع هناك جيوش هامشيه
ذكرت او وصفتها بالاحرى ماذا عنها وهل
نتوقع ان تتسع رقعه الاقتتال لتجلب هؤلاء
ايضا ومن سيكون مع من
للاسف الشديد يعني احنا لو سيناريوهات
التي نتحدث عنها
لخروج السودان من هذا المازق سترد على
سؤالك حول قوات الهامش اولا كلما وقع على
اتفاقيه جوبا وكل من وقع على اتفاق
الاطاري كان له بالاحرى ان يندمج داخل
القوات المسلحه
فبالتالي تم التاخر وتاخير هذه المساله
الى ان وصلنا الى هذه الى هذه الحاله التي
وصلنا
في السودان طيب
ما الذي سيحدث من يتحمل عن قصد طبعا عن
قصد وتعطيل عن قصد وتعطيل للاسف الشديد
الجيش كان يخشى من هذه المواجهه لكي لا
تنزلق الدوله في الاقتتال وكانت دائما
تنادي على على استحياء
باتفاقيه جبهه ولا بد من
اتفاقيه جبى بضم قوات
الهامش الى القوات المسلحه كذلك في
الاتفاق الاطار الاخير القوات المسلحه
والجيشه والمجلس السيادي
كان لابد من الدفع
قوات الدعم السريع الى التوقيع على دمج
قوات الدعم السريع في مده لا تتجاوز
الثلاثه اعوام الا ان الفريق محمد حمدان
دوجلو اصر على ان يكون عشره اعوام فان دل
على شان يدل على
ان هناك امل لبقاء عدد اكثر من اكثر من
قوه داخل السودان تحكم السودان السيناريو
اللي حضرتك تحدثت عنه ان هذه القوات
مجموعه منهم ستعود الى الهامش
وقوات
محمد حمدان دوقله اذا لم يتم اعلان عن
بحره رسميا سيكون هناك جيوب للخروج الى
الهامش ومن هناك تقتتم ومن هناك تعلن عن
دوله وتمزيق السودان هذا هو السيناريو
القادم الذي اتوقعه للسودان اذا لم يتم
حسم المعركه او اذا لم يتدخل الدول
الصديقه والمعنيه بهذه المساله بكل بسرعه
كبيره جدا او اذا لم تتحرك الاتحاد
الافريقي بكل حسم في هذه المساله او ان لم
تتحرك الدول العربيه متمثله في جامعه
الدول العربيه او متمثله في مصر والسعوديه
والامارات مجتمعه معهم جنوب السودان لان
اكثر دول لها تاثير في المساله السودانيه
هذه الدول الاربعه وانا اقصد بالرباعيه
اقصد هذه الدول لان لان الرباعيه السابقه
فشلت الرباعيه السابقه فشلت لانها لم تكن
تضم مصر وجنوب السودان
من هذه الرباعيه اعتقد انها هي مكتمله
الاركان اذا انضمت
دولتين كبيرتين عربيتين مثل السعوديه
والامارات واذا ضمت دوله كبيره مثل مصر
وجنوب السودان التي كانت جزء من السودان
او الحل العسكري اذا ما اخذنا الحل
السياسي شو طبيعه ما يمكن لهذه الدول او
هذه الجهات التي يمكن ان يكون لها التاثير
على الرجلين ان تحدث وهل بعد ما شاهدناه
الان يمكن العوده الى المطالبه بقياده
مدنيه العوده الى الاتفاق الايطالي وغيره
نعم نعم هناك نموذج يعني موجود للعوده الى
الاتفاق مره اخرى بعد الاقتتال لماذا ننسى
دوله جنوب السودان كان هذا السيناريو هو
هو المطروح سيناريو الاقتتال ما بين
الرئيس الدوله ونائبه ما بين سلفاكير
ورياكم الشار هل حتى اصبحت دوله فاشله وفي
كل
بقعه في جنوب السودان كانت هناك الدمار
ورائحه الموت تفوح في كل اركان جنوب
السودان لكن اليوم اصبحت بوادر دوله جديده
بعد الاتفاق بعد ما جلسوا وهناك دول كثيره
تدخلت منها اثيوبيا منها مصر مصر ساعه
كثيرا لتحقيق هذه
المساله
في في المصالحه الجنوب سودانيه الجنوب
سودانيه
وتم المصالحه
من خلال ايضا الاتحاد الافريقي
بالاتحاد الافريقي فلماذا لا يتكرر هذه
المساله مع
الفريق عبد الفتاح البرهان
والفريق محمد حمدان دوبلو لماذا نستبعد ان
يتم الجلوس مره اخرى والوصول الى التفاوض
حقيقي والاسراع الى دمج هذه القوات التي
تعتبر يعني انا في في عقيده القوات
المسلحه هي فعليا تعتبر ميليشيا
شردت من الجيش طيب بس على كل يعني لماذا
لا نتوقع لانه ما في ثقه بين الطرفين وهلا
رح نحكي عن هذا الموضوع من القاهره
الدكتور محمد عز الدين رئيس مؤسسه النيل
للدراسات الافريقيه والاستراتيجيه شكرا
جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
قالت قوات الدعم السريع في السودان ان
هناك مركزين للقرار الداخل قياده الجيش
وهو ما اعتبرته يهدد الالتزام بالهدنه
التي اعلنها الطرفان لمده 24 ساعه طبعا
باقي عليها حوالي الساعه والربع واضافت في
بيان لها ان التضارب في تصريحات قائد
الجيش عبد الفتاح البرهان والصفحه الرسميه
للقوات المسلحه بشان الهدنه يظهر وجود
مركزين للقرار داخل قياده الجيش
المزيد معنا من الخرطوم الدكتور عبد
الناصر سلم مدير برنامج شرق افريقيا
والسودان في مجموعه فوكس للدراسات اهلا بك
سيد اسمح لي ان ابدا بما قراناه من خبر
مؤخرا وتصريحات للدعم السريع تشكك فيه
بقوه الجيش وبقائه تحت قياده واحده تقول
ان هناك مركزين للقرار في الجيش هل هذا
جزء من
الصراع ما بين الطرفين والمشدات الكلاميه
ام انه بالفعل نلاحظ انه من خلال ما ذكر
حتى الان في الموقع وتصريحات الموجوده
انها ليس هناك نوع من الثبات
والروايه الواحده والموقف الواحد من قبل
الجيش السوداني
فقدنا الاتصال كان معنا من الخرطوم دكتور
عبد الناصر سلم مدير برنامج شرق افريقيا
والسودان في مجموعه فوكس للدراسات شكرا
على كل ونحاول العوده اليه طبعا الازمه
الراهنه شكلت ضربه جديده لاقتصاد البلاد
وايضا استمرار الصراع العسكري قد يجعل من
الصعب خروج السودان من الازمه الاقتصاديه
الضاربه بجذورها لعقود مضت
لا يمكن رسم صوره متفائله للاقتصاد
السوداني في ظل التصعيد المسلح بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع قبل هذه
الاشتباكات كان الاقتصاد يرزح تحت سلسله
من الازمات التي يعود تاريخها الى حقبه
الرئيس السابق عمر البشير واستمرت حتى بعد
سقوطه في 2019
الحكومه الانتقاليه التي تولت السلطه بعد
اسقاط البشير احيت امال السودانيين في
تحسن احوالهم اذ رفعت واشنطن بلادهم من
قائمه الدول الراعيه للارهاب وعادت
المساعدات الاجنبيه التي ناهزت ملياري
دولار سنويا الا ان الدول المانحه قررت
تعليق مساعداتها للسودان بعد الاجراءات
التي اتخذها قائد الجيش عبد الفتاح
البرهان في اكتوبر 2021
وشملت حل مجلس الوزراء والسياده
الانتقاليين مؤكده انها لن تستانف دعمها
للخرطوم ما لم تعد السلطه الى ايدي
المدنيين
الاقتصاد السوداني لم يشهد نموا منذ عام
2019 الا في عام 2021 فقد سجل نموا طفيفا
بنحو 0.5% لينكمش مجددا في عام 2022 صندوق
النقد توقع نمو اقتصاد السودان خلال العام
الجاري ب 2.5 الا ان الاحداث الاخيره قد
تعيد الاقتصاد الى مربع الانكماش ويحاصر
التضخم الاقتصاد منذ اكثر من ثلاث سنوات
فخلال 2022 ارتفع التضخم الى اكثر من 154
في المئه وفي يناير الماضي بلغت تضخم
السنوي نحو 83% لكن هذه الارقام كانت قبل
الازمه الراهنه بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع ويعتمد السودان على الخارج لتغطيه
معظم احتياجاته من النفط والغذاء وفي ظل
تدهور قيمه عملته وارتفاع الاسعار عالميا
سجل السودان خلال 2022 اعلى عجل في ميزانه
التجاري منذ 2012 ويساوي الدولار الواحد
حاليا في المتوسط نحو 600 جنيه سوداني
مقابل متوسط بين 18 الى 47 جنيها للدولار
الواحد في 2018 كل هذه العوامل انعكست
تدهورا في مستويات المعيشه واستراجع
القدره الشرائيه وارتفاع التضخم وارتفاع
مستويات الديون الخارجيه وغياب
الاستثمارات الاجنبيه وبالطبع وفي حال
تفاقم الازمه الراهنه فان كافه المؤشرات
الاقتصاديه ستسير نحو الاسوا محمد زهير
العربيه
مزيد معنا من الخرطوم دكتور عبد الناصر
سلم مدير برنامج شرق افريقيا والسودان في
مجموعه فوكس للدراسات اهلا بك دكتور هل
تسمعني بدايه يا مرحب بيك يا مرحب بك
استمع اليك دكتور عبد الناصر اقل من ساعه
وربع الان لتبدا هذه الهدنه ولا ثقه بين
الطرفين الدعم السريع يتحدث عن انه لا
قرار واحد داخل الجيش السوداني دعنا نتحدث
اولا عن ان كان بالفعل من خلال متابعاتك
وكما يقولون انه حتى الرسائل التي تخرج من
الجيش يبدو انها مقسمه على بعضها البعض
ربما تناقض بعضها البعض هل لاحظت هذا
الشيء او لا
هو على ما اعتقد انه الازمه السودانيه
التي تمر بها البلد في هذه الايام في
يومها الرابع سوف تقود بشكل او باخر الى
الى الى انزلاق الدوله الى حرب اهليه اذا
لم يكون هناك قدره ما بين الاطراف الدعم
السريع
والجيش للجلوس
والتفاوض والوصول الى نقاط تحقن دماء
السودانيين الاربعه ايام التي مضت الدوله
تدهورت فيها تدهورا سريع بصوره كبيره جدا
جدا في الخدمات نحن نتحدث الان عن خروج
اكثر من 80% من المستشفيات في ولايه
الخرطوم من الخدمه نتحدث اليوم عن توقف
الحياه بصوره كامله نتحدث اليوم عن القتال
يدور في قلب العاصمه
دكتور عبد الناصر ما بين الجانبين حتى
بالرغم من الاتفاق على هذه الهدنه كيف
تنظر الى ذلك
على ما اعتقد انه اليوم سوف يلتزمون بهذه
الهدنه لانه من الواضح جدا بان الطرفين قد
قد راوا ما حصل على ارض الواقع والضغوطات
الدوليه سوف تقودهم في نهايه المطاف
للالتزام بهذه المدنه والدخول في مرحله
بعدها في مرحله تفاوض مباشر ما بين
الفرقاء السودانيين لانه من الواضح جدا
بانه استمرار الح
في دوله اصلا تعاني من ازمات اقتصاديه
وامنيه وسياسيه سوف يقول في نهايه المطاف
الى انفراد عقد الامن في الدوله السودانيه
بصوره كامله ونحن اليوم في قلب العاصمه
القوميه انت لا تستطيعين ان تخرجي من
منزلك لمسافه قصيره جدا
ولكن دكتور تم تسريح كل
الشرطه او اعضاء الشرطه التابعين للدعم
السريع المواجهه بين الرجلين كانت قاسيه
جدا وبالتالي عندما تتحدث عن تفاوض ويقول
الجيش انه لا امكانيه للتفاوض ويجب انهاء
كليا الدعم السريع ورجالاته ما هي الاسس
التي يمكن ان تبنى عليها اي عمليه تفاوض
كل الحروب التي مرت عليها الدوله
السودانيه وكل الحروب على مستوى العالم
اختي الكريمه تنتهي في نهايه المطاف على
طاوله المفاوضات الحرب في جنوب السودان
استمرت اكثر من 30 عاما منذ 83 انتهت في
نهايه المطاف بمفاوضات وهذه حروب كانت
خارج المدن تفاوض مع من لانه دكتور عبد
الناصر الجيش يقول القضيه هي قضيه انهاء
لهذا الجسم كليا وبالتالي هل عندما نتحدث
عن امكانيه التفاوض يمكن ان تكون ما بين
الرجلين احمدتي والبرهان او لا يجب ان تتم
التصفيه اولا ومن ثم يتم الحديث مع من
تبقى التفاعل سوف يتم ما بين الرجلين لانه
هذه الاوضاع هي خساره للرجلين وخ
ساره بين البلد يعني في نهايه المطاف مهما
تطرقت الراء الاطراف المتحاربه في السودان
عليهم في نهايه المطر عم ينظروا من خارج
معسكراتهم ليروا ان الشعب السوداني اليوم
الى محرقه ليس له دخل فيها وفي نهايه
المسار سوف يجلس لتعويض المفاوضات لان
الحرب لن تحل اشكاليه في دوله اصلا تعاني
من كميه من الازمات ولا تحتاج لازمات اخرى
تفاوض على ماذا دكتور عبد الناصر وهل عدنا
الى المربع الاول الان للحديث عن العسكر
فقط ومن ثم يمكن فتح المجال للحديث عن
مدنيه الدوله وغيرها ام ماذا الان الخارطه
الخارطه التي وضعت لو الطاقه النار تتضمن
فتح ممرات امنه ايصال مساعدات
العمل على علاج الازمات المائيه
والكهربائيه التي
تعاني الدوله اذا ما تم الالتزام وانا هنا
اضع عده خطوط حول اذا ما تم الالتزام بهذه
الهدنه على ما اعتقد انها سوف ترسل اشاره
واضحه بان الطرفين يرغبون في ان يتم حل
سلمي لهذه الازمه لانه من الواضع على ارض
المعركه ان الطرفين قدراتهم متقاربه جدا
جدا يعني نحن اليوم في اليوم الرابع
الوتيره الصراع ما زالت مستمره الضحايا ما
زالوا يعني لا يجدون علاجا وهذه في نهايه
المسؤوليه الاطراف بعد ذلك ممكن ان تجلس
الاطراف لتتحدث عن صيغه سياسيه تقود الى
معرفه مستقبل الدوله او حل الخلاف بصوره
كامله ما بين الرجلين واذا فشلت الهدنه شو
السيناريوهات المطروحه
اذا ما فشلت الهدنه واتمنى الا تفشل على
ما اعتقد بانه سوف يكون سوداوي جدا على كل
السودانيين استمرار الصراع بهذه الصوره
سوف يقود الى ان كل طرف سوف يحاول ان يحشد
قواته في العاصمه وفي الولايات وان الصراع
بعد ذلك سوف يتحول الى حرب مدن في في في
في مدينه فيها فيها اكثر من 9 مليون مواطن
اليوم يعانون من نقص في كل مقومات الحياه
هل تتوقعي بان هل تتخيلي من اربعه ايام
هناك مناطق كبيره في في العاصمه لا يوجد
فيها ماء لا توجد فيها خدمات المستشفيات
خرجت من الخدمه كل سبل الحياه الكريمه
توقفت وفوق ذلك هناك
قصف وهناك
بمدن او حرب شوارع ما بين الاطراف
المتناحره انا هنا في نقطه مهمه ما بينها
هذين الطرفين اذا ما استمرت او انه ستتوسع
الدائره
من من
الممكن ان تتوسع الدائره ويدخل لاعب اخرى
للجهات اخرى في هذا الصراع لانه الفراق
الامنيه عندما يتسر سوف ياتي لاعبون اخرون
ليحاولوا ان يملاوا الفراغ باجل اجندتهم
السياسيه او العسكريه انا هنا لا اريد ان
اتحدث عن جهاز محدده لكن السودان اي فراغ
في السودان ستتحاول مجموعات متطرفه من
البلدان الاخرى التي اصلا فيها اضطراب ان
تملا هذا الفراغ في في الداخل السوداني
وهذه سوف تكون كارثه كارثه ليس ليست على
السودان فقط كارثه على حتى على البلدان
المجاوره يعني انا هناك بلدان مجاوره
للسودان فيها صراعات وفيها مجموعات متطرفه
عندما تشعر هذه المجموعات بان الامن عقد
الامن قد امتلت الدوله سوف تحاول ان تخرج
او ان تاتي الى هذه الدوله لتحاول ان تجمع
قواتها وتعيد بناء نفسها مره اخرى كان
معنا من الخرطوم الدكتور عبد الناصر سلم
مدير برنامج شرق افريقيا والسودان في
مجموعه فوكس للدراسات شكرا جزيلا لك
هذا وادعها مدير منظمه الصحه العالميه
تدرس
طرفي الصراع في السودان لاتاحه امكانيه
الوصول الى المرافق الطبيه وقال انه من
الواجب على جميع الاطراف التاكد من اتاحه
القدره على الوصول غير المقيد والامن الى
المنشات الصحيه لجميع المصابين والذين
يحتاجون لرعايه طبيه
المزيد معنا من الخرطوم اللواء الركن
دكتور محمد نعمه نعمه الله جبريل الباحث
في الاستراتيجيات والدراسات المستقبليه
اهلا بك لواء اسمح لي ان ابدا بقضيه غياب
الثقه ما بين الجانبين وحديث الدعم السريع
لانه القرار داخل الجيش ليس لشخص واحد كيف
تقيم هذه التصريحات هل هي جزء من الحرب
الكلاميه ما بين الطرفين ام ماذا
شكرا جزيلا والتحيه التي
لمستمعين الكرام ومتابعيكم
انا حقيقه مساله القرار في القوات المسلحه
ليس لشخص واحد
ذكر غريب جدا هو اصلا القرار اصلا ينبغي
ان يكون شخص واحد
القرار العسكري يكون لشخص واحد وبتكون
هنالك منظومه اسمها منظومه اعداد
ودعم
وصياغه القرار يعني هذه المجموعه هي
الدعم يتم بواسطه المعلومات
والاعداد من خلال المعلومات يتم يعني
دراسه علميه ولكنه يشير دكتور محمد معله
التصريحات تشير وكانه هناك اكثر من جناح
داخل مظله الجيش السوداني
الكبير هو ذاته يتحدث
شخص من اي جهه اخرى عن
ما يدور في القوات المسلحه ده كلامه صحيح
الاساسيه
في القوات المسلحه
قرار هو واحد طيب ومن خلال متابعتك طريقه
التعاطي مع ما حدث خلال الاربع ايام الى
ان وصلنا الان الى هذه المرحله حيث نتحدث
خلال بعد حوالي الساعه من الان
عن الهدنه هل جرت بما يجب ان يكون عسكريا
او لا
وحقيقه الامر القوات المسلحه تفاجات بهذا
الحدث وبهذا التمري
علي
الخطب التي وضعت
يعني
دحر هذه التمرد خطه سريعه وخطه مفاجئه
ولكن انا احب انها خطه كانت حسب التسلسل
وحفظ الطريقه العلميه
وبفتكر القوات المسلحه ادارك هذه الخطه
بنجاح تام وبحيث انها عملت مراحل ومن انس
الناطق الرسمي للقوات المسلحه تحدث لانه
هذه هي المرحله الاولى من خلال المرحله
الاولى لانه اساسا لا يمكن ان تنفذ الخطه
ثم انت نعم
الدكتور محمد نعمه الله جبريل الباحث في
الاستراتيجيات والدراسات المستقبليه شكرا
جزيلا لك وبهذا نكون قد وصلنا الى نهايه
التغطيه حتى هذه الساعه لراس الساعه رينبو
قمرا والتغطيه مستمره ابقوا معنا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات